[Applause]
I'm really glad that mr. Pratt is here
hopefully she can bring some some sanity
to this is really getting its work out
today hi Pete how are you welcome Pete
we're just glad that you didn't sit
there and miss Pat didn't sit where you
are cuz then they would have thought we
arranged Lucas - oh that's like they
always [ __ ] I met them for the first
time last night and I was like how -
[ __ ] y'all smell alike the same body
odor
we use the same Cologne they shower
together like old rednecks nice beard
I'm just saying he'll look like John
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
this is actually a beautiful reunion
wasn't it last year that Bob and Miss
Pat became like close friends here in
Montreal a few years ago we break
meatloaf together what do you say we
split meatloaf yeah we don't eat meat we
start I want you to go through your life
believing the white people don't eat me
black people don't eat white people meet
black me though y'all put raises that
you meet
I think that's true what your meatloaf
is a musician that's not me I'm a sexual
wages like if a plane went down I'm
going for meatloaf first gonna steam is
coming gave yourself a delicious name to
pals together one step together Bob's
like two pounds eight ounces
[Laughter]
I just couldn't do the math we climb we
meet a Tim Dylan went to it was one of
us wasn't gonna make it up the hill and
cuz we told was a dick old town
mountainous him yeah yeah he was gay he
is yeah yeah but she caught us in the
woods happy was the mountain that's now
a valley
[Laughter]
Jim actually got to the top and gonna
you've got an icy screen but no you did
that's right they both got to the top we
got ice cream Wow what the [ __ ] we walk
thank you that gives me a motive to walk
up there crying motivation you let's all
say it you know he's not committing a
crime honey help your husband now
correct his words anymore I got better
things to do now I don't start teaming
up on him again don't start teaming up
it's definitely not well he's got two
kids from previous my life my ex-wife
who I miss dearly and the Bonnie and I
have an 11 year old who's a [ __ ]
genius straight A's everything who she
gets that from you know one of you guys
can cross your legs like that not all
three
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
this is the most comfortable way don't
stop
well at least you do it so it looks like
nothing happened that's a good twin jug
where were you it's not gonna play on
the radio it's only gonna play in the
room I sold out my twin French for
nothing nothing they got it you guys
didn't get it they got it they were like
oh great they just hate talking about
being twins it's all you
six-six I have a theory with twin
comedians though you guys must get
recognized 10 times more than any of us
because people look at twins anyway
people look at all people anyway like
you hang out with the Sklar brothers I'm
like Jesus Christ how famous are these
guys is cuz everyone looks at them and
and recce know we were getting like like
people would you say oh you guys are
twins and you guys are cool like when we
became comedians it was just like a
natural right yeah it's like you
answered the call yeah you're getting
recognized might as well get paid for it
yeah
so what did you get what's your guys
names I just know Lucas brother I don't
[ __ ] cute what's your last name
my last night Paisley oh is it I got
health care so I kept the Lea part
okay hey Pete what are you doing up here
hey I'm hosting new faces I came in I
wanted to I think some people asked me
who was it somebody in the elevator was
wait your friend was like you're hosting
new faces and I was like yeah I wanted
to look I wanted to do it because I feel
like it's the realest show in Montreal
it's gonna sound like a line but like
who cares that Trevor Noah is you know
here he is doing the Bell Center yeah I
know we don't all care and wish him dead
- Trevor it's just part of his tour yeah
I'm not puttin down Trevor I'm saying
it's just another show on his tour - the
new faces if I could matters to these
kids and I say kids they're all in their
30s but like I wanted to give them a
good show and do my part I feel like I
feel very paternal I did the show it
feels like a family and would give them
a good show you're doing this for the
industry I'm doing a prison for the
industry you're doing it for comedy I
remember how nervous I did it 10 years
ago and I don't know there's I just want
to like I'm basically like doing warm-up
I'm like yelling at the audience I'm
making fun of them for not paying
attention or making fun of them for not
laughing I'm screaming at them saying
this is their dream are you gonna
withhold their dream and that gets them
going and then and then I do some new
material so they could follow me easily
and they're [ __ ] killing it they
don't need any of it they're really
really great Bobby who's hosting
fat faces cruel what is hosting old
washed-up not gonna make it's never got
new faces very effective very good
talking about him like that's right so
what he got three faces they don't win
stuff they don't laugh at fast where are
they why did you get up at 9:30 to sit
out on jokes honey wake the [ __ ] up so
why are you here I don't understand
we're on the radio that was a very mean
comeback though I was mean that hurt me
when you hit boss when he hit boss yeah
well you know what my old watch a lot of
never never oh yeah all those yeah calm
down yamaneika
[Applause]
[Laughter]
the fat girls right when she's hanging
out look like somebody killed a deer
from the back damn cop me no goddammit
I'm sorry yamaneika patchouli you have
his luck Toph a girl god I slipped it
was an accident
I know I know she did shake off yo ass
why do you got on the lane like mr. t
you look at your face looks like you
[ __ ] Oh
nothing
look at your bracelets like your
successful gold and upgrade all the time
twin bayon - don't tell me you got
pregnant on twin Bay they're getting
offended at the twin
[Applause]
and you're laughing so much now like
this is why they want
I need to be funnier people being funny
and you're like oh dear from the back I
don't even know if I get it but you said
like did she kill the deer from behind
no from behind it looks like she killed
the deer how does an ass look like a
deer what she's black
is she like you don't look at black ass
from the back yeah so fat you can see it
from the front that's a most def lyric I
thought that's what we're all oh I'm
sorry I thought we were all cool
picked up the slack for your show what
do you think Sam killed a deer from
buying it out yeah well that's what it
looked like on yamaneika as movies ever
seen a deer from behind that's it that's
better that's a bad that's a better
question yeah you've seen a deer from
behind yeah with the white fluffy part
that's what you put it in oh I'm sorry
am I the only one that's cool
I'm listening to mos def I'm [ __ ]
deer in the wild dirty Pete Holmes I
love it yeah animals the deer that
there's something there's a vibe yeah
their dainty they're walking around Andy
they're always looking at you just yeah
you [ __ ] a pig you're an [ __ ] you
[ __ ] deer I'll hear you means you're
Swift
please silently not letting it know
you're there they're always presenting
that's what I mean they're presenting
the next time you see y'all my [ __ ]
gonna be looking up ahead I'm gonna be
attracted to her for two reasons we can
say yeah Monique and then we'll get
everybody picking up the slack yeah well
yeah I don't know what I just got lost
in that last one yeah so did I by I just
got lost in her blouse to me you got
lost in my blouse
it's a blouse right it's a shirt a shirt
blouse when she put it on this one it
was one flower
if you think of that I need to know it
just hit me know me I'm an ad-lib ER
there's different styles there's the
Hitman guy that'll think of that when
she comes in and goes I'm gonna wait
till she's mean rich vos dotnet I'm
assuming rich just like a tennis coach
yeah like you've ever played there's
something else going on it's never my
fault
I'll find a reason I'll be like there
was a role that was too good dressed
like a football it got lost in the your
own show yeah we've been talking a lot
we're just enjoying your gift I'm not
looking at you I'm looking at the other
one he said two [ __ ] you didn't say
ass all I would just shut my mouth and
let him I believe Sam has two [ __ ]
Thank You Bonnie
in college that thought everybody had an
anus and a butthole mineralogy
yeah twenty where'd you go to Penn State
nor do can make a girl because they
would see I'll think about that now make
a girl I got confused like make yeah
you're right that's funny no stop trying
to make [ __ ] out of nothing mari and I
were to argue okay coffee I'm sleepy as
a [ __ ] really this is you sleepy
Jesus I'm about to retire I can't handle
this I feel like a weather man I'm just
like you'll notice the hurricane is
moving to a new topic
[Laughter]
Bobby and I were talking about breaking
balls like I haven't done this in a long
time and it's really nice and I was
sorry breaking balls
there was one flower on your shirt when
you put that on there broke your snaps I
thought you'd sell my crackle pop
crackle pops - Siri no no of course we
know rice krispies is not an established
fat guy treat but it's still work
I'm only here to do commentary like
maybe rice krispie treats is a rice
krispy is Bobby tried to slim down he's
like yeah I'm trying to get a new thing
going frosty right crew yeah you're
right delicious yep Frost any of them
frosty rice krispies what what is joning
it's Ronin yeah we call it jump I never
heard that I've never heard that
I know it's called joning have you guys
heard that Joe we call it hiking hiking
we can we say joning I'm from Georgia
good natured ribbing and
that's your next record Jim Norton a
good natured ribbing it was like a big
lolly on the press your sweet record van
Dijk [ __ ] you
nobody really did oh man no it wasn't
alright whatever you can say jounin or
hiking or ball-breaking or ribbing never
really hurt my feelings the only people
that have heard me in comedy are
audiences and then we started talking
about that we were like is is the
ribbing you're interrupting me
nationally televised radio show that's
right and my asinine comment does not
deserve to be interrupted by your coffee
critique what's wrong with it I'm a
grown-ass woman my [ __ ] gotta be right
where's Dan's yeah let's get let's get
this [ __ ] a little bit more right ladies
and gentlemen please welcome to
Dan Soder from the bonfire by the way
what stand how much space you're giving
up I appreciate this just like a wave
pool you did predict Jim that this is
the way it would go yeah I did but Dan
Soder would represent the bonfire J
somewhere
we're both pooping at the same time
texting so I think I finished first
that's where our poops are synched time
to poop is big J see a doctor today is
Jay here or is he uh yeah I think so
okay all right no he's not in the room
but he you know he's in motion all right
I hope he comes in well welcome Dan
Soder dan you're performing a son of
Gary at 9:00 at the Cafe Cleopatra maybe
not even a name it's just me doing an
hour yeah Gary's well they're just you
know they're like they had to give a
name and why that and funny was taken
this whole press conference look for you
does it look good
like what did you think of that was it
before I'm gonna say it looks like a
press conference no yeah he looks like
the manager of a baseball [ __ ] prison
baseball team from the bag yeah and I'm
like look at that dear but we don't know
each other that well sorry how's your
how's your going it's good cafe
cleopatra's a fun venue what are you
shooting in October well uh Bowery
Ballroom in New York um so I'm going to
Edinboro I go to Ireland tomorrow and
then you know go to a bunch of foggy
places where they don't like comedy yeah
well your face is perfect
thank you I think I think I got it Bobby
your pity your face is perfect for fog
isn't it no Stonehenge he's got a big
old head a head on that line maybe it's
bigger than Barney let's how do you were
I got a big [ __ ] head let's go right
now head off
Norton relax not that one that big head
what size fitted hat viewer I don't know
but they don't give it out at the
ballpark when it's like it's fitted at
dam like na for PD it's crying giant
tears day at the ballpark what's your
what's your hat size Dan eight that's
felt like you wanted to brag about
that's a giant head here and a limo in
Dallas the [ __ ] bullets bounce off
[Laughter]
size eight-six guy is it's the largest
fit of heaven what do you think I like
the Lucas brothers wearing I don't know
anything but hat sigh what sigh what a
normal sized head be a something much
bigger
what do you guys wear no but it's
difficult to find it's usually right
yeah
thank you it when you have a lot of hair
oh yeah yeah or if your hair situation
is gonna change a fitted cap has an
added feature it tells you when you need
a haircut white people white people love
this they're right here it is weird to
see momentum stop so completely there is
an audience if I had like a ukulele and
I go a fitted cap as an added feature
long pause ukulele solo and I go it
tells you when to get a haircut standing
over it yeah like that standing ovation
just not this room no no
what's up James nobody else can fit on
his [ __ ] couch we can't have - go
okay yeah mama it's all good moving over
J we didn't think you're gonna come with
glad you came we figured that you was
sleeping J you're looking more and more
medium J yeah yes Jay oakerson small J
looks specifically on that couch you
look amazing yeah wondering and I just
[ __ ] baby wipes
yes J has to clean us ass in the
business but you two got it I know about
you but yeah why is he so Clint doing it
the way it cleans his ass yes well it
should be a class whoa whoa cuz Jim is a
professional mass wholesaler he cleans
it with his own fingers Jim Cleese your
radio host the radio host yeah I'll put
my co-hosts clean but yeah I will do an
[ __ ] battle right you lose my [ __ ]
[Laughter]
let me ask you this this is a gym
technique that I found out about raps
the toilet paper around the guy's [ __ ]
what kind of fluid does Jay use to wash
out the inside his gym he [ __ ] beat
me down with ass clean and Lance is it
true I woke up in my bed right now I
would not be surprised I was yeah yeah I
had a dream I was on your show and then
I was so clearly fake because he started
talking about ass cleaning techniques
and everyone was just listening like
but oh I'll take that down like in the
dream this should be a lot better while
you're doing it I mean is you using it
no how do you clean it yeah
oh boy I don't even wipe good did you
what the [ __ ] it's also important
oh I start well I said I start before I
even sit down by spreading butt cheeks
so when you sit down the seats holding
your ass open so you're not even getting
cheek involved in the process no one
does that with hands especially a little
tiny baby rings on children's hands well
let me let me ask you this so you're
using physics to hold your [ __ ] do
you insist on [ __ ] in the nude no oh
really because a real clean [ __ ]
professional would [ __ ] in the nude if I
closed at my ankles do with hold on a
second you know why Jay has to do that
he has to do that probably because
there's a lot of hair in your [ __ ] me
[ __ ] not a hair smooth as a baby's
ass smooth as a baby's ass no it's
natural
nothing naturally naturally hairless
delicious [ __ ] that's my tinder
profile I'm sorry I said Glendale
[Applause]
[Laughter]
somebody's really pulled it off Brandon
yo G so Natale to ripping your hair I'm
just a hairless I have a couple little
wispy fellas but I'm very hairless he
grew up near power lines I'm not a hairy
person no he's not here so far your
hairy
your mother was a bird you wouldn't have
hair either my mother was a bird she
would land on your back
but honestly it works so well I was like
that can't be what it means it's gotta
be like a radio show call back it's like
birds on the back on the face or
something I don't know it was a straight
[ __ ] hippler joke I'm proud of
everybody involved arguably sweet it was
like a sweet joke I loved it so you say
you spread your booty cheeks for the
toilet the whole yeah so long that's
painfully [ __ ] what's that [ __ ] a room
that [ __ ] hurt but for the record
gesture be like a play-doh Fun Factory
making a shape you want to you know let
it know you do it I'm saying you do it
you do it by virtue I'm sitting down
he's just my cheeks are something gets
stuck back then I need to shake it out
what so you spread after the fact he's
spreading before the incident but he got
the toilet hey holding his [ __ ] open
sure [ __ ] in peace with the toilet
spreading your booty that's to keep the
cheeks clean I understand the thing you
understand a little pain now to avoid
some pain later let me ask you this but
just just so we have the scoreboard
clear right now we have Harry and
clothes versus nude and hairless I woud
I've been assigned hairy [ __ ] yeah I
don't think I actually have a very hairy
[ __ ] I do I look back there it's all
tactile that's why you gotta hear the
process this [ __ ] guy he just who
your [ __ ] manager should
rich gonna tell them yeah pitching a
reality show in a room talk about your
[ __ ] like boss Don King James oh
you're spread open on via the toilet
seat mm-hmm and then how does the
process continue are we body I don't
thank you for saying that I'm here
spending years trying to get J on a
squatty potty yeah you look like the
before picture on a squatty potty hints
like an unhappy guy that could be
[ __ ] better get on that body
I don't I've already got my ass cheeks
wide open I can't have my knees at my
fault oh you haven't you seen the
animation with the unicorn and the ice
cream look it doesn't it doesn't strike
me that big Jay is the guy that needs
his [ __ ] technique rated he seems
like he's got a hand along yeah I had a
handle on it I thought yeah and then I
always get credit where credit is due
he's gonna be humble here but Dan Soder
for a long and I'm not alone in this
I've learned people will turn on me here
but for a long time even with my
obsessive cleaning techniques I was damn
could still taste it
[Laughter]
you're not doing a good enough job so
Lucas brothers do y'all do y'all what
did you learn I have to know what you
this is gonna sell to people done this
for years it's gonna sound stupid to
them but I was always a as soon as
you're done [ __ ] immediately stand
up and start wow wow what reaiise it was
a you should do a little bit while
you're sitting still will you touch as a
kid I don't know [ __ ] and stand up and
get mushy cheeks together Thank You
Bobby
never never never even over thought that
what that's that's a real why are you
down you get more out of it no cuz you
want to pulling it back either to your
spine or to your balls it just spreads
out the problems a day long how you have
the balls
I'm sorry so when you you saying the
best way as a white why you said now
well that's the beginning of the process
I stand up
you do are you do horses wipe a [ __ ] can
stand up to why wait do you not are you
are you done wiping lawyer City yeah
they're gonna be nut butter sandwich
that's why you so much tissue if you
white boy you see my arms are short I
can't reach back there please can you go
through I need a peanut butter sandwich
like it was a clinical term
like the show is so funny that peanut
butter sandwich is just like the whole
come on it comes off medicinal a
condition called cottage cheese so you
stand J give me the steps here cuz you
gotta figure out who's better sitting
several baby wipes while sick Oh baby
why be a baby laughs question she turned
up anybody can [ __ ] have an immaculate
ashes a baby well that's like I hire
someone to hose it out yeah would you
explain it's not [ __ ] that's not you
think it's like you think I'm using your
juicing your juicing I get my [ __ ]
clean with just [ __ ] paper and the
will to do it explain our professional
walk to work mentality never use if I
had them sure I just don't think to
happen but you but you don't think you
so you wipe your ass with dry paper with
with wipes I come on it's not even a
kind of conversation get your ass fully
clean yeah peanut butter what's that you
know I go in there dry I [ __ ] put one
foot on the ball one foot I arch my
[ __ ] out and I put fingers trust me
it's immaculate we just took it to
another level
that's ridiculous [ __ ] that's like Jim
saying he only reads Maps and doesn't
use Google Maps but he gets their donut
on it like you're taking a [ __ ] staff
ya know one foot on the toilet on the
floor but yeah I understand I got your
back yes I can push push my ass out and
get in yes you have to arch it well yeah
yeah like you you get up one leg up
aren't you back and stick two fingers
not true they're just as clean as deep
as you can but the but the baby wipes I
didn't even always even thinking don't
come in here with that kid [ __ ] like you
wipe your ass professionally when you're
dealing with Jim Norton on paper a
challenge that just give me baby wipes
wiping your [ __ ] is just spreading
your ass bro my god
my guy is using [ __ ] way rich don't
want to tell him bonnie is about her guy
you ever used newspaper he's not a poor
neighborhood lot plus you'll explain to
him what one is newspaper if I might
edition I gotta get something that she
had yeah paper towels first we didn't
have paper towel we're coming up we tell
you you never have fried chicken and put
it on the newspaper I'm I'm gonna do
that she did it yeah you pick up the two
that all everything is on the back of
your chicken privilege as white people
we do chicken with the news on it
grazing in your meatloaf that's a
45-minute call
are you a squatty potty I had one with
the knees up I loved it but then when I
moved I didn't grant but you do [ __ ]
better with your knees up yeah get that
and what about a bidet I have I have one
of my toilet I throw great for 10 years
ya know the best thing ever is there
anything that you can do to compete with
the technique of putting the one foot on
the ball arching the back or that amount
of thought being put into it is there
anything that you can do to compete with
that I just do that with about five
minutes of other nonsense before that
tell me wait till Jay gets to face all
right
where's your hands show your hands
before you're asking these questions
[Laughter]
I'm a lefty masturbating he's a sweet
boy he looks like he's gonna teach us
all the paint slow-release I could I
feel like could map this room with sonar
without tell us you take my so I do the
baby wipes from side cheeking lifting
and then when I stand up a lot of times
Bob you could probably appreciate this
my legs are dead put my forehead against
the bathroom wall to get the tickles out
of my leg because I still want to get to
wipe it but my legs aren't working so
I'm just rest my body on my head and
then continue I'm gonna need an applause
who's who's doing a second round of
wiping well Stanley I'm just curious no
judgment and that's zero now you see why
I'm so confident in Jays clean butthole
I don't know if that's that sounds like
OCD Peter white Glover check two
Knuckles deep right you could go two
knuckles
oh he's showroom clean all the time Jim
how many knuckles could you sticking
your knuckles in yeah I got two knuckles
I beat that when I was nine
I only have one knuckle wait very clean
are you squatting when you say standing
you you mean a squat like you're really
stuck on this standing in show me please
show me how are you doing it I just mean
what are you doing there there is a
process show us how you do sure keep the
deer in the stage [ __ ] that's a
22-minute called like the face of my
palm to spread the cheeks open again yet
again and then with the paper hold the
mic no no no this is why we gave him the
wireless yeah paper wrapped around many
finger and then going back in for about
I mean I'm like a three flusher I really
I've just pure wipes
Wow Gaia cries wipes of toilet paper
what why so you're standing and
recreating the situation you just had
effortlessly while seated
nothing has changed by standing yeah you
do get better than no did you change by
saying you standing 200 every time I
never I don't wipe at all when I said no
man machine arrived you want to point
out if rich stood - white would all be
like you [ __ ] dummy he stood - why he
be the same Heidi is now
[Laughter]
it was a short joke bunny do you go
through all of it no I I can't even
believe we're still talking about this
Jesus and we got vagina and it leaks
your vagina leaks the tumor you also got
stories I think vaginas leak that crazy
processor happens in public I'm the same
way I'm weird where I [ __ ] I did shoot a
whole private game or hotel room yep I
hate what I can hear hustle and bustle
around me sexually adventurous I'm not
saying this to be I'm not burning you
I'm saying you're sexually adventurous
and yet in the bathroom you want pure
private yeah it's all part of the same
yes when I have an emergency one time
there was Yellowjackets flying between
my legs I was walking to steal comic
books I just [ __ ] in the woods
and I [ __ ] my yellow jacket now sitting
outside is weird because terrible how's
it go in the water you can see how big
your [ __ ] really yeah you don't take a
[ __ ] you abandon a ship what are you
white when you [ __ ] at those leaves yeah
that was on my underwear I wipe my ro
threw it out that's the move that was an
emergency the move that was an emergency
what I used one sock heathermills on my
hand do both socks for continuity you
look like a crazy person you just [ __ ]
in the woods
no like gyms got the fog of war nobody
knows won't say why are you not wearing
socks but they will say why are you
wearing one yeah where's your the sock
that's right
see ukulele stuff it could be for me
[Laughter]
when did you [ __ ] outside bob was it
Rica's you do more camping more outdoors
camping when you do like bushcraft stuff
do you [ __ ] you have to dig a hole [ __ ]
in it bury it it's quite a hole and then
what do you wipe with because you're
white you write don't paper toilet paper
nice you bring it put that in the hole
cuz that's biodegradable of course and
then you have you get a baby wipe that
you have to take out with you yeah you
have to put the baby wipe hack it away
so you try to [ __ ] as wipe as much as
you can with that and the baby wipe is
just to make sure there's no you know
stuff peanut butter on there gosh then
you put that in the Ziploc bags and take
that out yeah are you flashing your baby
noise I don't flush baby one no I'm
asking mm-hmm I'm asking old stand and
wipe you're flashing tomorrow yeah oh
yeah the city of New York thanks you
you're basically clogging the [ __ ] of
your city I'm a paper mache a [ __ ]
sewer elevator what are you doing in the
woods your bushwhackers bushcraft
bushcraft what is that Bob is one of the
bushcraft party boys not everybody knows
that but that's what he does outside of
comedy yeah me yeah me Ari Shaffir Joe
list we go hiking in the woods with
knives
we all have nice when you say hiking you
mean like a drive no we do hike up
we are doing [ __ ] we are got with the
woods and we camp out in the woods okay
I'll tell you what we did I went with
him the one time no you didn't go with
us
Oh buddy I went with you we can't big
man no that's camping got you I
understand however though a big thing
this was centered around was gonna be
this hike no that wasn't a hike you're
right it wasn't wait
well let's see let's hear what big Jays
interpretation is there's no
interpretation
okay facts what happened and quick right
just I'd find it bore it but then Bobby
starts doing when I write this just come
on dude you could do the hut such
challenging me where I'm like I'm
definitely more athletic than Bobby I'm
like why is he challenging me like dude
you'll be able to do it don't worry
[ __ ] it's condescending yeah so I was
like we're all going and then all I knew
was we broke off on to past two
different groups and I stayed with the
Bobby path because I knew very quickly
it was gonna be I guess we could just
hang here and look at this lake we went
down here's a problem re was there and I
really likes just walk in the woods
Harley and you know he goes into the
woods and then comes back an hour later
very dangerous my god we went down the
hill and then there was a point with you
like I'm done I'm out did you did you
say that big J not even damn did you
could wait Dan yeah right here dandy big
takeaway corporate [ __ ] Dan's not
gonna take a side no it was it wasn't a
hike it was a walk up a hill and then
down to a lake and then we all know we
walked up halfway re-split
and then we walked down you walk up and
around no we walked down we went down
but maybe Dan wasn't the right guy
[Laughter]
bothering the degree up and over cuz
that's when Orion like five feet and
then we went down with it there was a
beautiful Corgi on the truck yeah yeah
you [ __ ] Walt we did somebody the
question some der re all the way down
right to where the waterfall was right
we decided you know what this is enough
and we went back i we it was wasn't me
yeah I think we're just gonna hang out
okay
do you like you were like I'm dead I
think you lines never I walk the [ __ ]
Mountain would he thank you
what dude I'm telling you like I never
get to be mean it was ice cream at the
top of that people that have read one
book and you work it into every that he
can [ __ ] do it with the mashed
potatoes I know but so far we're at two
confirmed votes that bob is the one that
stopped that is true and not gently not
that you can hear at one it was aunt
Angie official quit I just had a feeling
if I stayed close to Bobby
there wasn't a whole bunch of hike it go
and you're right if I went Yuri
direction I debated that you're right I
may have quitting so I tell you why I
wanted the disc to trails there's one
that went all the way down to the
waterfall right that's how you got a
clean [ __ ] right there if you're a
clean [ __ ] guy who get to waterfall
oh there's the hike around the lake I
wanted to do around the lake right cuz
it was a longer hike but it wasn't so
all the way down they have to come all
the way back up sure
and would you just roll all the way down
those energies just gone
I've been here since 8:00 I've given
enough that's it
so watch Rose calm I believe Bobby
Bobby's walked uphill a mile two miles
to on hikes you know he sees snakes and
[ __ ] he's told me these stories and I
[ __ ] believe but he might have been
lying then two stories he's not gonna
lie about that about audience members
but he's not gonna live hiking he's a
true hiker he really is I believe you
gonna stand will go with the pack Dan
him all they don't want to do with this
date I was part of all of it they didn't
want to go all the way down and I are
you went all the way down I said we
should go back up we'll go to the lake
we'll hang out at the lake and then we
can walk around the lake that's what I
said we can do yeah just a different
height this is a dream this isn't real
there's no way I'm on a radio show where
Bobby's like I stayed outside yeah we
had to get a cabin for you to [ __ ]
Evil's did you guys need a cabin but all
six they needed a cabin for sure yeah
they had to get a cab disappointing no I
was in a [ __ ] hammock between two
trees you was not too sad trees
there's no way Allstate no but you'll
stay outside in your circus tent right
hammock it's a no but you gotta sleep at
night right why in the tent you brought
Ken I know what you're doing trying to
slow roll can you think of something cuz
you don't got it hey I know what you
doing you saw you have everybody's sling
you hang your food up so the Bears don't
get it slow rolling you're right
meandering so jokes on guys
yeah doing exactly what Pete called you
out of the beginning I loved it I'm very
curious
no it's very fitting to get burned by a
guy who looks like a tanning bed came to
[Applause]
[Laughter]
listen I'm trying to bring it back for
you you steam crazy bombs or I got a fat
joke I predict calm down you buddy sound
like you ain't breathing over there
Pete's leg weirding the twins out
[Laughter]
hashtag me to 90
[Laughter]
because I could tell you weren't joking
crachek canceled
yeah with Janssen thank you very much
for coming home it was a show about a
comedian in New York and open oh yeah I
didn't hear it's okay it was on HBO so
rich you were you're talking about Bob's
food in that being hung up he knows
everything about camping he does we know
everything I know something's you know a
lot about it gone out to the woods like
not on a trail that trail we were on was
the road I've gone out the woods me and
I reach oh me and falls out of the woods
woods and just make a campsite and stay
for the night I've done that I believe
in you baby thank you pat they talkin
that [ __ ] I've seen you camping on
Instagram thank you so um what do you
know were you gonna say about the food
being hung up no he knows all the tricks
he'll hang the food I said nothing can
we stop while you're doing this old man
do the other campers put their food in
the bag yes L do so bye
I got it I got it you bought yourself
enough time for me to come new comedy
team he made fun of Bob's appearance
sitting here I was like fat camping fat
camping what do we got we got there real
good one more Jim and Sam catch up with
full episodes and interviews from
celebrity guests anytime on demand using
the Sirius XM app